Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先和大家分享一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊发起的“冲刺持续收入挑战赛”。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What is sport and exercise psychology and what additional challenges might there be
这些原则对你同样适用。本次挑战赛还设有由丽莎亲自颁发的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特恩特博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们进入今天的节目。什么是运动与运动心理学？对于那些并非在英国出生和长大的人来说，
for someone pursuing a professional qualification if they weren't born and raised in the UK? This is a fascinating episode where we look at the constituent parts of sport and exercise psychology, what the work involves, what the study involves and what the career options are once qualified. I am joined by Dr. Dawn Marie Ambrose, a qualified sport and exercise psychologist who has a really interesting story to tell. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I love to be able to introduce you to have deeper dives into different psychology professional areas. And sport and exercise psychology is one that we've not
追求专业资格可能会面临哪些额外的挑战？这是一期精彩的节目，我们将探讨运动与运动心理学的组成部分、工作内容、学习内容以及获得资格后的职业选择。今天和我一起做客的是唐·玛丽·安布罗斯博士，她是一位拥有真正精彩故事的合格运动与运动心理学家。希望你觉得这期节目非常有用。嗨，欢迎来到“有志心理学家播客”。我是玛丽安·特恩特博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。我非常喜欢带大家深入了解不同的心理学专业领域。而运动与运动心理学是我们很少
covered very often on the podcast. And I still think regardless of what area of psychology that you want to go into, there is so much to be gained by listening to different practitioners talk, hearing about their life stories. So even if sport and exercise psychology is not your passion, I think there is so much that you might find useful about today's episode. Just after we finished recording, my expert for today, Dr. Dawn, and I were discussing the process of visas. And I came across looking quite naive, but I guess we have to know that we can't always know what we haven't experienced. And every day is a school day. What I hadn't realised is actually it's really quite expensive to get visas to work and study in the UK. And we're often talking about multiple thousands of pounds.
在播客中探讨的领域。但我依然认为，无论你想进入哪个心理学领域，通过聆听不同从业者的分享和他们的人生故事，都能让你受益匪浅。所以，即使运动与运动心理学不是你的热情所在，我也认为你会从今天的节目中发现许多有用的东西。就在我们录音刚结束时，我今天的专家唐博士和我讨论了签证流程。我当时显得相当天真，但我想我们必须明白，我们不可能对未曾经历的事情都了如指掌，而且活到老学到老。我之前没有意识到的是，在英国工作和学习的签证费用其实相当昂贵。我们通常谈论的是数千英镑。
And so that is something I hadn't been aware of. Did you know? Do come and let me know over on socials. Come and join the free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, which is the only home of my free weekly videos, Marianne's Motivation and Mindset, which happens on a Friday morning. So do come and dive in over there. With no further ado, let's meet Dr. Dawn. And I hope you find this a really useful episode and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi and I hope you find this a really useful episode and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi I just want to welcome along Dr. Dawn Marie Armstrong who is a sport and exercise psychologist. Hi Dawn. Hiya thank you for the invite today Marianne how are you? Oh thank you for saying yes I know it's taken us a little while to to sort out a date because we're
所以我之前并不知道这一点。你知道吗？快来社交媒体上告诉我吧。快来加入免费的 Facebook 群组“有志心理学家社群与玛丽安·特恩特博士”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent），这里是我每周免费视频《玛丽安的动力与思维》（Marianne's Motivation and Mindset）的唯一聚集地，该视频于每周五早晨播出。所以快来加入吧。话不多说，让我们来认识唐博士。希望你觉得这是一期非常有用的节目，我期待在节目后半部分与你交流。嗨，希望你觉得这是一期非常有用的节目，我期待在节目后半部分与你交流。嗨，我只想欢迎唐·玛丽·阿姆斯特朗博士的到来，她是一位运动与运动心理学家。嗨，唐。嗨呀，谢谢你今天的邀请，玛丽安，你好吗？哦，谢谢你答应参加，我知道我们花了点时间才定下一个日期，因为我们
both busy people but I really wanted to have a think with you about you obviously but also what sport and exercise psychology is and how people kind of can begin to explore that um as a career option so firstly tell us a little bit about yourself. All right. So, yeah, I'm Dawn. So for me, I think my journey into the field as a practitioner, presently being transnational. So I am not British. I am here working as a professional through what would be the international study route, I wrote my master's here. Then I completed my doctorate here. And as a result of that, I have been able to capitalize on the opportunities as a skilled worker.
都是大忙人，但我真的很想和你聊聊，不仅是关于你，还有什么是运动与运动心理学，以及人们如何开始将其实用化——作为一种职业选择。所以首先，请给我们简单介绍一下你自己。好的。所以，是的，我是唐。对我来说，我认为我作为一名从业者的职业旅程，目前具有跨国性质。因此，我不是英国人。我是通过国际留学生途径在这里作为专业人士工作的，我在这里攻读了硕士学位。然后我在当地完成了博士学位。正因为如此，我能够抓住作为技术工人的机会。
Yeah, from the beautiful Caribbean island of Barbados. So I am presently the first from the Caribbean to be on the HCPC register from a BPS accredited doctoral route. And it was no easy undertaking. I think for me, when I consider the field of sport and exercise psychology and where my passion came. So my views on what it was when I first started has changed. Obviously, now being in the UK, practicing, working. And I definitely feel now that the field has evolved to a point where not only do we as professionals focus on the optimization of athletes' potential, we support their well-being, we support performance predominantly,
是的，我来自加勒比海美丽的巴巴多斯岛。因此，目前我是英国健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）注册名单中，第一位通过英国心理学会（BPS）认证的博士路线获得资格的加勒比海人。这绝非易事。对我和我所从事的运动与运动心理学领域以及我的热情的来源而言，我刚开始时的看法已经发生了变化。显然，现在身在英国执业和工作，我绝对觉得该领域已经发展到一个阶段，我们作为专业人士不仅专注于优化运动员的潜能，我们支持他们的福祉，主要支持他们的表现，
and it all depends on the philosophical underpinnings of the practitioner. Speaking to myself more specifically, I've diversified my practice, not just to focus on, you know, the performance benefits, but to actually utilize my voice as a means of social advocacy within the field. So focusing a lot on equality, diversity and inclusion and supporting athletes who are struggling with issues like racism within sport, discrimination. I'm really focusing my lens on, you know, marginalized communities within sport. So I would say typically, yes, working with athletes to optimize potential, but definitely recognizing that in order to optimize the potential of the performer, we first have to focus on them as a human being.
这一切都取决于从业者的哲学基础。具体到我个人，我使我的实践多样化，不仅关注表现方面的益处，还利用自己的声音作为该领域社会倡导的一种手段。因此，我非常关注平等、多元与化（EDI），并支持那些在体育运动中挣扎于种族主义、歧视等问题的运动员。我真正将目光聚焦于体育界中被边缘化的群体。所以我想说，典型的工作是与运动员合作以优化潜力，但绝对认识到，为了优化表演者的潜力，我们首先必须将他们视为一个人来关注。
And looking at some of the challenges that people face, it is sometimes difficult to focus on them as a human being and looking at some of the challenges that people face it is sometimes difficult to focus on performance only um so yeah well-being and performance but definitely focusing on those issues that impact us as individuals as well and unfortunately racism happens to be one of them yeah absolutely um that was something that I discussed with Daniel Gennardu, who is a professional football player. And he's also got a first class degree in psychology and he's kind of heading towards the hopefully sport and exercise. But I asked him about racism in football and he actually said that it's not really something that he's come up against which kind of made me feel excited for for the change really and it's something I've seen with my children they just don't seem to see skin color um in the way that I think certainly many of us did when we were younger like
审视人们面对应对的一些挑战时，有时很难只关注他们的表现，嗯，所以福祉和表现，但绝对要关注那些作为个体影响我们的问题，不幸的是，种族主义恰恰是其中之一。是的，绝对的，嗯，这是我和职业足球运动员丹尼尔·热纳尔杜讨论过的问题。他还有一个心理学一等学位，他正朝着希望从事运动与运动心理学的方向发展。我问过他关于足球中的种族主义，他实际上说这并不是他真正遇到过的事情，这让我对真正的改变感到兴奋，而且这也是我在我孩子身上看到的事情，他们似乎不会看到肤色，
I don't know what your experience is of I mean you weren't raised in the UK but how how is that for you as a person of color but also supporting people of color and you know what will you people yeah who are not um you know people of color how's that from your perspective I think for me coming from a country where I was not a minority, I definitely feel I do have very much a larger than life personality. And I think that's not something that's changed while being in the UK. I think having your skin color politicized is something that I think over the years of being here, you know, ticking a box to say, oh, you black caribbean you know um equality and diversity diversity monitoring and you know all of these other things that you just you definitely find in barbados it's a bit like okay well um 95 of us are black anywhere um i definitely feel
就像我年轻时很多人肯定做过的那样，我不知道你的经验是什么，我的意思是，你不是在英国长大的，但作为一个有色人种，这对你来说是怎样的？但同时也支持有色人种，你知道，你会对那些不是有色人种的人说……从你的角度来看，这感觉如何？我认为对我来说，来自一个我不是少数族裔的国家，我绝对觉得我有一个非常充满活力的性格。我认为这在英国并没有改变。我认为你的肤色被政治化了，这是我认为在这里待了多年之后的事情，你知道，勾选一个框说，哦，你是个黑人加勒比人，你知道，嗯，平等、多元与化监测，你知道所有这些你在巴巴多斯绝对找不到的其他事情，这有点像，好吧，嗯，我们当中95%的人无论如何都是黑人，我绝对觉得
that some people and it was interesting because i had someone say to me that they just don't understand the issues that some people face and interestingly enough if people tell you that they're not experiencing racism chances are is that they really just don't have the capacity to deal with it and oftentimes people overlook some of the things that may happen within their environment see small microaggressions you know because if you dwell on them and you ruminate then it has more of a detrimental impact to your performance and this isn't just within sport this is in general um that some people just choose to overlook some of the things that are happening whereas some people do the exact opposite so you and i would both know considering you know psychological evaluation and intake and
有些人——有趣的是，有人对我说过，他们只是不理解某些人面临的问题，而有趣的是，如果人们告诉你他们没有经历过种族主义，很有可能他们真的没有能力去处理它，而且人们往往会忽视环境中可能发生的一些事情，看到微小的微观侵略（microaggressions），你知道的，因为如果你纠结于它们并反刍它们，它会对你的表现产生更多有害的影响，这不仅在体育运动中，在一般生活中也是如此，有些人只是选择忽视正在发生的事情，而有些人则恰恰相反。所以你我都很清楚，考虑到心理评估和接诊评估，
assessment it's that individualized approach the support that you provide so so if an individual definitely says this doesn't happen to me you know it's not up to you to say well it is happening if that individual believes that this isn't happening and it's not a thing then we just have to accept that for some people experiences are different. Unfortunately for some of the people that I engage with, it isn't so. And I focus more on that person-centered approach because if we are not valuing people as individuals, sport for example, and I go on and on and on because of the idealistic nature of it, oh, we don't see color, you know, everyone is united, you know there's no racism in sport but people are suffering um in the background unwilling to speak up because they
这种方法是个性化的，是你所提供的支持。因此，如果一个人明确表示这没有发生在我身上（你知道的），那么如果这个人认为这没有发生而且这不是一回事，你就不能说这正在发生，我们只能接受有些人的经历是不同的。不幸的是，对于我接触过的一些人来说，事实并非如此。我更多地关注以人为本的方法，因为如果我们不把人视为个体来重视，以体育为例，我之所以不断提及，是因为它具有理想主义的性质，哦，我们看不到肤色，你知道，每个人都团结一致，你知道体育运动中没有种族主义，但人们却在幕后默默承受痛苦，不愿大声说出来，因为他们
don't want to be victimized and they don't want you know some of the backlash that comes from speaking about issues like racism so that's why i've taken it as a responsibility to speak up whether or not people believe you know you're making an issue of something that's not an issue believe it or not it's an issue for many and people just don't want to talk about it um so yeah to answer your question it has been interesting um but I'm grateful to have the upbringing that I've had because my identity is more than secure when it comes to dealing with these issues and I think less of critical impartions. Thank you for speaking to that point and you know I was really struck by what you said you know in Barbados actually 95% of people are black and so it's that very much experience of
不想成为受害者，也不想招致谈论种族主义等问题所带来的反弹。这就是为什么我把大声说出来当成自己的责任，不管人们是否认为你在把不是问题的事情当成问题，信不信由你，这对许多人来说确实是个问题，而人们只是不想谈论它。所以，是的，回答你的问题，这段经历很有趣，但我很感激我有过这样的成长经历，因为在处理这些问题时，我的身份认同是非常稳固的，而且我也较少受到批判性输入的影响。感谢你谈到这一点，你知道，我对你所说的话深有感触，在巴巴多斯，实际上95%的人都是黑人，所以这非常像是一种体验，
now perhaps feeling othered being being in the UK even though not 95% of people are white here there's loads more multicultural kind of aspects but very different that feeling of being different or feeling different when actually you're still the same person but you're in a different setting but you know I'm torn I'm torn between congratulating you for being the first um you know but i think what did what did you say the first person from the caribbean who is an hcg registered yes bps or so it's just sport and psychology yeah so i'm torn between congratulating you but also i don't know like a bit dismayed that it's 2024 and you have to be number one you know yeah yeah the expense the investment again you know leaving
现在在英国可能会感到被边缘化或产生“他者化”的感觉，尽管这里95%的人口并非全是白人，还有更多多元文化的因素，但那种感觉大不相同——当你实际上还是同一个人，却身处不同环境时，那种感到与众不同或格格不入的感觉。不过，你知道，我很纠结，我既想祝贺你成为第一个，你知道的，但我想，你刚刚说什么来着？加勒比地区第一位获得HCPC注册、BPS认证的运动心理学家，是的。所以我很纠结，既想祝贺你，但又不知道为什么，有点沮丧——都2024年了，你还得当第一名，你知道的。是的，费用，投资，再次离开
the Caribbean and being faced with the very real I'd say xenophobia sometimes there's a bit of sexism there is racism you know within the fields and yeah having to adjust to that um from 2018 until present. Sometimes I don't even know how I got to the end because in reality, you're just faced with barriers at every turn. But yeah, God is good. Here I am. And definitely opening doors for persons who wish to follow.
加勒比地区，并面对真实的、我可以说有时是仇外心理的情况，领域内存在一定程度的性别歧视、种族主义，你知道的，并且从2018年至今不得不适应这一切。有时我甚至不知道我是怎么走到终点的，因为在现实中，你每转过一个弯都会面临重重障碍。但上帝保佑，我走到了这里。我也绝对在为那些希望效仿的人敞开大门。
Yeah, once you can see it, you can see it you can be it can't you and so you know i know there will be lots of people out there who are growing up possibly listening to this podcast um we have people who are doing their a levels or gcse sometimes or undergrad that are like oh right yeah oh okay um yeah so yes thank you for your perseverance and was it your experience I know you you've been a keen cricket player throughout your life was it your experiences in cricket that that turned you on and made you aware of sport and exercise psychology yeah I think this is something that we spoke about before we started. It was that element of being a female cricketer and, you know, exploring the fact that maybe our version of the sport wasn't going to be as
是的，一旦你看到了，你就能看到它；你就能成为它，对吧？所以，我知道外面会有很多人，可能正在听这个播客，我们有正在读 A-level 或 GCSE 的人，有时还有本科生，他们会说：“哦，对了，啊，好的，嗯。”所以，是的，谢谢你的坚持不懈。那是你的经历吗？我知道你一生中一直是一名热心的板球运动员，是你在板球运动中的经历激发了你，让你意识到运动与运动心理学吗？是的，我想这是我们在开始之前讨论过的事情。那就是作为一个女性板球运动员的经历，并且探索这样一个事实：也许我们版本的这项运动不会像男子的版本那样
rewarding as the men's version and deciding, you know, I want a degree. I already have my bachelor's degree by the time I represented my country. So I've played for Barbados. I played for the West Indies A team back in 2011 before I started my master's. And yes, I did get a scholarship in terms of starting the master's and completing it. And just recognizing that it was natural
那么有回报，于是我决定：我想要一个学位。在我代表国家出战时，我已经拿到了学士学位。所以，在我开始攻读硕士学位之前，我曾在2011年为巴巴多斯效力，为西印度群岛A队效力。是的，在开始攻读硕士学位和完成学业方面，我确实获得了奖学金。我只是认识到，顺理成章地进入运动心理学领域
to kind of like go into sports psychology. Interestingly enough, I would have thanked the person that kind of steered me along the road because I was kind of, yeah, battling between sport and criminology. Well, criminology primarily and some person was like, no, Dawn, sports psychology. And I was like, oh, I came to England for my first season as an overseas and just started exploring, know postgraduate degrees degrees in sports psychology this was around 2010 and yeah 2011 that's when I started and I definitely feel like I was thinking more about perhaps the long term not wanting to particularly retire from
是非常自然的。有趣的是，我要感谢那个指引我走这条路的人，因为我当时在体育和犯罪学之间摇摆不定。好吧，主要是犯罪学，然后有人说：“不，唐，选运动心理学。”我说：“哦，我为了我的第一个海外赛季来到了英国，并开始探索体育心理学的研究生学位，这大约是在2010年到2011年，我就是那时开始的。”我绝对觉得我当时考虑得更多的是长远发展，不想过早地从
cricket too early but seeing how my postgraduate qualification could be incorporated into supporting persons like myself. But equally on the Masters, there was so much teaching that was applicable to me as a performer that I think I just learned and grew throughout the course of study. So yeah, female cricket's a really, really bright prospect at the time I was a fast bowler. One of the fastest, if not the fastest in the Caribbean. And yeah, I just thought it's not working out in terms of, I guess, making a career out of cricket.
板球运动中退役，而是看看我的研究生学历如何能够融入到支持像我这样的人的工作中去。同样，在硕士课程中，有如此多的教学内容适用于我作为一名表演者的身份，以至于我认为我在整个学习过程中不断学习和成长。所以，是的，女子板球当时是一个非常非常有前景的前景，当时我是一名快球运动员。我是加勒比地区最快的快球运动员之一，如果不是最快的话。是的，我只是觉得从把板球作为职业发展的角度来看，这行不通。
Obviously that's changed, but I'm happy that I chose the professional route and I definitely feel that this chose the professional role and I definitely feel that this will be more rewarding for me in the end. Yeah and I think it's it kind of future proofs you as well because in any sport people are going to age out of a system where they're playing it themselves and where they then either sit on the sidelines and wish they were doing it or you coach and support the next generation but you know that sounds like a decision that you made you know sounds like one of the fastest bowlers in in the Caribbean which is amazing but is that something that you
显然情况已经改变了，但我很高兴我选择了职业道路，我绝对觉得这条职业道路最终会给我带来更多回报。是的，我认为这也为你未来的职业生涯做了保障，因为在任何体育项目中，人们都会随着年龄增长而退出自己参赛的系统，到那时要么坐在场边希望自己还在场上，要么去执教并支持下一代，但听起来这是你做出的决定，听起来像是加勒比地区最快的快球运动员之一，这太棒了，但这...
step back from or is it that you were like well I'm doing this instead? Honestly it's interesting because when I came up to the UK I was based in Scotland and I did play a season in 2018 so technically I'd say my last season was 2018 but obviously recognizing the you know the climate differences I think in terms of playing and then thinking how cool they used to be sometimes at the start of the season I just started to question whether or not it was something that I wanted to do, again, because of the studies and the commitment that would have come from wanting to have a cricket career, I think, in the UK. It just wasn't going to work. In line with the visa, number one, and number two, I just did not have the time and the commitment to
退一步讲，还是说你当时想的是“算了，我还是做这个吧”？老实说，这挺有意思的，因为当我来到英国时，我在苏格兰落脚，并且在2018年打过一个赛季。所以严格来说，我会说我的上一个赛季是2018年。但显然，考虑到气候差异，我认为从打球的角度来看，然后想到赛季初的时候曾经觉得有多酷，我开始质疑这是否真的是我想做的事情，再次因为学业以及想要在英国开启板球职业生涯所需要的付出，我认为在英国这根本行不通。首先是签证问题，其次是我根本没有时间和精力去
do it um so yeah I'd say I kind of stepped to where I look back now and think did I really want to in the sense that did I did I not challenge myself enough to give it a real go um recognizing that ageism is a big thing in in the sport as well and I always think I was early 30s and there were younger girls coming up through the setup and different things so no I think no I'm definitely glad I made the decision um at the time I was always very much you know the cricket bag is still there go and turn over your hand and I did that while I was in Liverpool in 2022 and they wanted me to play an entire season so I was just like you know you still got it but you just don't have the time to commit to it so I think I I've just got the bag there and you never know but it's definitely not wanting to be a cricketer anymore okay and oh gosh that
完成它。所以，是的，我会说我当时算是退让了，现在回想起来，我真的想过吗？也就是说，我是不是没有给自己足够的挑战去真正尝试一下？同时我也意识到，在体育界，年龄歧视也是一个很大的问题。我总是觉得自己当时已经三十岁出头了，而有一批更年轻的女孩正在通过青训体系涌现出来。所以，不，我不后悔，我绝对很高兴自己当时做了这个决定。当时我基本上还是觉得，“板球包还在那儿呢，去转转手腕试试吧”。我在2022年身处利物浦时就这么做了，他们希望我能打完整整一个赛季，所以我当时就觉得：“你宝刀未老，但你就是没有时间去全身心投入。”所以我想，我把包放在那儿，世事难料，但我绝对是不想再当职业板球运动员了。好吧，天哪，那
must have been quite the adjustment going from Barbados to Scotland like I think I would struggle going from Coventry to Scotland so that must have been wild definitely oh let's not chat about the whole call it was oh my goodness yeah so you mentioned the bps route for sport and exercise psychologists could you tell us a little bit more about what that is and you know how that plays out what that looks like for people yeah um so there are two routes towards qualification in sport and exercise psychology there's the independent route so this would be QSEP stage two usually what you would do or at least yeah I'm gonna say back in my day because obviously I wrote the master's over a decade ago you had to have something called GBR graduate basis of registration which was formerly known as GBC graduate basis of
从巴巴多斯到苏格兰，一定是个相当大的适应过程吧。我觉得如果让我从考文垂搬到苏格兰我都会很挣扎，所以那一定很疯狂。绝对的，哦，咱们别聊那种冷劲了，我的天哪。是的，所以你提到了运动与运动心理学家的BPS（英国心理学会）路径，你能多给我们讲讲那是什么，以及它是如何运作的，对人们来说到底是怎么样的吗？好的，嗯，通往运动与运动心理学资格认证有两条路径。一条是独立路径，这通常是QSEP（运动与运动心理学资格）第二阶段。通常你会怎么做，或者至少——我要说“在我那个年代”，因为我写硕士论文已经是十多年前的事了——你必须拥有所谓的GBR（研究生注册基础），以前被称为GBC（研究生
chartership and essentially I had to get my degree from Barbados accredited in order to get the GBC GBR to write the master's and the master's was stage one and because you've got the master's as BPS accredited then you are able to enroll onto a BPS stage two however because I was an international student, I was not able to write the independent stage two because the BPS presently doesn't provide sponsorship for international students to stay and continue. So as a result of completing the masters, I did receive a PhD scholarship at the time. However, due to it's a bit of wanting to stay knowing that I should have stayed and written the PhD, but feeling as if I had a commitment to stay home based on the opportunities
特许基础）。基本上，我必须让我在巴巴多斯获得的学位得到认证，才能获得GBC/GBR来撰写硕士论文，而硕士阶段就是第一阶段。因为你的硕士学位获得了BPS认证，所以你才能注册BPS第二阶段。然而，由于我是一名国际学生，我无法参加独立的第二阶段考试，因为BPS目前不为留学生提供签证赞助，以让他们留在英国继续深造。因此，在完成硕士学位后，我当时确实获得了博士奖学金。然而，由于一方面有点想留下来——我知道自己本该留下来攻读博士学位——但另一方面又觉得自己对家乡有一种责任感，因为我通过获得的
that were provided through the different scholarships that I would have received. And yeah, I went back to Barbados and it was just difficult to qualify because the BPS does not allow you to qualify remotely. You have to spend 51% of your time in the UK. And because practitioners who are overseas have difficulty securing employment, it wasn't possible to come back. However, the prof. wrote was introduced, which then would allow me to return to the UK as an international student.
各种奖学金得到了许多机会。所以，是的，我回到了巴巴多斯，但要在当地获得资格认证很困难，因为BPS不允许你远程完成认证。你必须在英国度过51%的时间。而且由于身处海外的从业者很难找到工作，所以根本无法回去。不过后来推出了职业博士项目，这随后将允许我以国际学生的身份返回英国。
And in writing the professional doctorate, which is another qualification in line with the QSEP, I was able to then return as an international doctoral trainee and complete in that respect. Obviously more expensive than if I were able to write the independent QSEP but I think in the end very much more rewarding in terms of developing my skills and my experiences academic and other ways so yeah. Okay so that's self-funded. I actually received a government scholarship so I received a scholarship from the government of Barbados again because sports psychology was seen as an emerging field so it was called a national development scholarship and my tuition was paid by the government a stipend provided
通过撰写专业博士论文——这是与QSEP相符的另一项资格认证——我得以作为一名国际博士生返回英国，并在那方面完成了学业。这显然比攻读独立的QSEP要贵，但在培养我的技能、学术经验以及其他方面的经历上，最终证明是非常有价值的，所以，是的。好吧，那是自费的吗？其实我拿到了政府奖学金，我拿到了巴巴多斯政府的奖学金，同样是因为运动心理学当时被视为一个新兴领域，所以它被称为国家发展奖学金。我的学费由政府支付，并且在第一年还提供了生活补贴，
within the first year but mainly when I look back at the length of time it would have taken to complete I almost spent triple that so I would say yeah technically self-funded getting to the end um but really yeah I think had not for the scholarship from the government of my country I think the opportunity to return may have been a lot more difficult given that I would have previously written a degree as well yeah okay yeah self-funded the master's was definitely self-funded right and what does the actual study involve so are you having to work with a certain number of people in different sports are you having to do presentations and essays and exams tell us a little bit about the nuts and bolts of it if you will yes so the doctorate is mapped on to four key roles um key role one being cpd and ethics key
但主要当我回想完成它所需的时间时，我花的几乎是三倍的时间。所以我想说，严格来说，走到最后还是自费的。不过说实话，如果没有祖国政府的奖学金，考虑到我之前也已经读完了一个学位，想要返回的机会可能会困难得多。是的，好吧，硕士确实是自费的。那么，实际的学习包含哪些内容呢？也就是说，你必须和特定数量、不同运动项目的人一起工作吗？你必须做演讲、写论文和参加考试吗？给我们讲讲它的核心实质好吗？好的，这个博士项目对应四个核心角色：
role two being consultancy so this is where you do the bulk of your client work um key role three being predominantly research and key key role four being dissemination and teaching, teaching and dissemination. So essentially what you have to do is evidence over the course of your enrollment that you are engaging with field specific CPD. So this will be conference attendances, you're undertaking your certificates, you know, to evidence your practice. So I would have done a CBT course course an REBT course I actually embarked on mental health first aid as well I just thought it was something very useful given the fact that I do predominantly work within youth sport and being able to support
核心角色一是CPD（持续专业发展）和职业道德；核心角色二是咨询，这是你进行大量客户工作的地方；核心角色三主要是研究；核心角色四是传播与教学，即教学与传播。所以，基本上你必须在注册期间提供证据，证明你正在参与特定领域的持续专业发展。这包括出席会议、获得证书，以证明你的实践。因此，我参加过CBT（认知行为疗法）课程、REBT（理性情绪行为疗法）课程，我实际上还进行了心理健康急救培训，我只是觉得这非常有用，因为我主要在青少年体育领域工作，能够支持
young people in that regard who may be faced with you know crises at the point in time I thought it was a valuable qualification to have. So yeah, attended the BPS conferences, attended different workshops. And what I did find is that when it came to Key Road 2, a lot of these CPD events and, you know, these qualifications that I obtained as a result of this did definitely inform my practice. So some of the case studies that I have undertaken well on the doctorate, one is already published and another has been recommended for publication. So you'll see that hopefully in a few weeks time, I'm hoping not a few months, a few weeks. But yeah, so the research, I have my systematic review published, I am in the process of, you know, structuring or restructuring the independent submissions. These will be the empirical papers, again, for publication.
面临当时危机的年轻人，我认为这是一项很有价值的资质。所以，是的，我参加了BPS会议，参加了不同的研讨会。我发现，当涉及到核心角色二时，许多这样的CPD活动以及我因此获得的资质，确实为我的实践提供了指导。因此，我在博士期间进行的一些案例研究中，有一个已经发表，另一个已被推荐发表。所以希望你在几周内——我希望不是几个月，而是几周——就能看到它们。但总的来说，关于研究，我的系统评价已经发表，我正在构建或重构独立提交的论文，这些将是实证论文，同样是为了发表。
So I'm hoping to see the majority of my work published within the next 12 months. And teaching and dissemination, I worked at a university in Scotland throughout the latter stages of the doctorate and then I utilized the workshops that I delivered while you know in my job while I was on the doctorate I've said that like four times in my job um I have done that and yeah so the teaching the workshops everything that I did educating persons on sports specific um psychological principles um went into key role for as well so it was really exciting you know looking at the development and looking at my reflections and meta reflecting um about my development over the four years um it was supposed to be two but in terms of the pandemic and I also had my daughter during that
所以我希望在未来12个月内看到我的大部分工作得以发表。至于教学和传播，我在博士学位的后期曾在苏格兰的一所大学工作，然后我利用了在工作中以及攻读博士期间发表的研讨会——我刚才好像说了四遍“在我的工作中”——我做到了这些。是的，教学、研讨会，所有这些向人们普及特定运动心理学原理的事情，也都归入了核心角色四。所以这真的令人兴奋，看着自己的发展，进行反思，并在四年里对自己的成长进行元反思——本来应该是两年，但因为疫情，而且期间我还生了女儿，
time so I became a mum yeah my daughter was born in 2020 so yeah it wasn't it wasn't clear cut for me but definitely rewarding in the end. Ah well welcome belatedly to the mummy club um the most stressful hopefully rewarding club you'll ever be is she interested in cricket has she picked up a cricket bat yet she's she's three she is she is very she swims um i actually don't plan to sample sports just yet i'm waiting for her to say, Mommy, I'm interested in something. But she is very, what's the word, verbally advanced. At three and a half,
所以我当了妈妈，是的，我的女儿是2020年出生的。所以，是的，我的道路并非一帆风顺，但最终绝对是值得的。啊，那迟来的欢迎加入妈妈俱乐部！这或许是有史以来压力最大、但最值得的俱乐部。她对板球感兴趣吗？她拿过板球拍吗？她三岁了，她真的很喜欢游泳。我其实还不打算让她盲目尝试各种运动，我在等她自己说：“妈妈，我对某某感兴趣。”但她非常——怎么说呢——语言表达能力很超前。在三岁半的时候，
the conversations that she has with me is just a bit, hmm, she wants to study and get A's. So it's interesting. If she isn't sporty, I don't think I'd be the least bit bothered. I just want her to be whoever she is.
她和我进行的对话都有点……嗯，她想学习并考高分。所以这挺有意思的。如果她不擅长运动，我想我一点也不会烦心。我只希望她做她自己。
And I think that's the most important thing because I was mothered in that way. And my mother allowed me to be whoever she knew I was going to become. So I think I'd apply those same principles to my daughter. Yeah, and I, speaking as a woman, I feel like sport wasn't ever really offered to me. So there was stuff that was happening in school that was compulsory, but I probably wasn't very good at everything. My mum, I remember her playing badminton in the garden and her not wanting to play with me because I wasn't very good. And it's like, it's not very nice.
我认为这是最最重要的，因为我妈妈就是这样抚养我的。我妈妈允许我成为她所知道的我终将成为的那种人。所以我想我会把同样的原则应用到我的女儿身上。是的，作为一个女性来说，我觉得运动从来没有真正向我敞开过。所以学校里有一些是必修的活动，但我可能并非样样精通。我记得我妈妈在花园里打羽毛球时，因为我打得不好而不愿意和我玩。这就感觉……挺不高兴的。
She'd play with my brother. And I just very quickly got messages that I wasn't very sporty and I didn't pursue anything. But actually, what I've learned since probably becoming, so I'm now 40, I'm going to be 43 in a couple of weeks time but what the pandemic taught me is actually you don't necessarily have to love the sport while you're doing it to feel the benefits of it so I started like many of us I started to put on a bit of weight during the pandemic when I was sitting on my bum more um and I started to run um and I'm still running now. I'm not I'm not very good at it, but that doesn't matter either. I really enjoy it after I finished it. And my body, my mind responds really well to it.
她会跟我弟弟玩。我很快就接收到了一些信息，觉得自己很不擅长运动，于是我什么也没有去追求。但事实上，自从我大概——我现在40岁了，过两周我就要43岁了——自从到了这个年纪，大流行病教会我的是：其实你不一定非要在运动的同时就爱上它，才能感受到它带来的好处。所以，就像我们许多人一样，当我在大流行期间更多地坐在屁股上时，我开始发福了，于是我开始跑步。我现在还在跑。我跑得其实并不好，但这也没关系。每次跑完后我真的很享受。我的身体和心灵对它的反应非常好。
And I have wanted I've got I've got two children, 10 year old and a seven year old. I really wanted to to put sport and exercise more on the map than it had been for me so that it's an option um and so we've joined a gym as a family um in the last week um and today we're going off to do paddle for the first time which is a little bit like badminton a little bit like tennis I think it's somewhere between the two and it's like I've never done that I'm almost 43 and they're getting to hopefully experience sport in a way that feels fun feels exciting um and I just hope that they can then make more mindful choices about sport so I've actually got into strength training in the last two years
我一直想要——我有两个孩子，一个10岁，一个7岁。我真的想让运动和锻炼比过去对我的影响更重要，让它成为一种选择。所以过去一周我们全家加入了一个健身房，今天我们要去第一次尝试板网球（Padel），它有点像羽毛球，又有点像网球，我觉得介于两者之间。就像我从来没有做过那样，我都快43岁了，而他们正以一种感觉有趣、感觉兴奋的方式体验运动。我只希望他们能够对运动做出更有意识的选择。所以我其实在过去两年里开始接触力量训练，
and I love it and it's not something I ever would have thought I would love and I just I just want people to be more mindful about them and exercise and you know benefits it might bring for them yeah so another another and I probably should have alluded to this earlier. So you are introduced to exercise psychology in your postgraduate study. And as you get on to the roads for qualification, you do have a choice to decide whether you want to specialize in exercise psychology as well. So there are practitioners, because of the ACPC accredited title of sport and exercise psychologists, there are practitioners who are sport and exercise psychologists who predominantly specialize in exercise. So I think for me, when I engage with clients who are interested in the psychological principles of exercise, I utilize my experience as a sports psychologist predominantly to use those principles to assist persons who are interested in exercising. But I don't particularly tell people that I am an
并且我爱上了它。这不是我以前会想自己会喜欢的东西，我只是希望人们对他们自己、对锻炼以及锻炼可能带来的好处有更多、更清醒的认识。是的，所以另一个——我可能早点就该暗示这一点了。你在研究生学习期间接触到了运动心理学。当你踏上资格认证的道路时，你确实可以选择是否也想专攻运动心理学。因此，有一些从业人员，由于拥有ACPC（英国心理学会特许运动与运动心理学家）认证的头衔，他们是主要专攻运动心理学的运动与运动心理学家。所以我想对我来说，当我接触对运动心理学原理感兴趣的客户时，我主要利用我作为运动心理学家的经验，来利用这些原理协助那些对锻炼感兴趣的人。但我并不特别告诉人们我是一个
exercise psychologist, whereas some of the exercise psychologists that I know predominantly work in, you know, fitness settings, for example, and assisting clients who are somewhat sedentary by applying the principles of behavior change and allowing them to feel empowered as a result of you know utilizing exercise to enhance be it well-being obviously in most instances I think a lot of professionals who specialize in exercise psychology find themselves on exercise referral schemes so providing that support for persons who again may be struggling to you know have an active lifestyle and showing them the benefits that can come as a result of that so a lot of persons who have been diagnosed
运动心理学家，而我认识的一些运动心理学家主要在健身房等环境中工作，通过应用行为改变的原则协助那些有点久坐不动的客户，使他们在利用运动来提升福祉的过程中感到被赋予了力量。显然在大多数情况下，我认为许多专攻运动心理学的专业人士发现自己参与了运动转诊计划，从而为那些可能仍在努力拥有积极生活方式的人提供支持，并向他们展示由此带来的好处。因此，许多被诊断出
with like you know health issues for example who have to, psychologists are there to support them along, you know, those routes. There are programs, for example, for people who are struggling with weight and they have psychologists to support persons to put interventions in place to support people in that regard. So, yeah, there is tremendous scope for both sport and exercise. But as a practitioner and discussing my sporting history, we've come to recognize that I am definitely a sports psychologist. And I have no regrets. Yeah, that's really interesting to split the two parts of that qualification that actually you're qualified in both. But your professional interest is more in the sport and the the professional sport player yeah definitely yeah um professional sport player yes
患有健康问题的人，例如必须接受支持的人，心理学家会在这些道路上陪伴支持他们。例如，有一些针对体重管理困难人群的项目，心理学家会提供支持，帮助这些人实施干预措施。所以，是的，无论是运动还是锻炼，都有着巨大的发展空间。但作为一名从业者，在讨论了我的运动历史后，我们已经认识到我绝对是一名运动心理学家。我对此毫无遗憾。是的，把资格认证的两部分拆分来看真的很有趣，实际上你在两方面都具备资格。但你的职业兴趣更多在竞技体育和职业运动员身上，对吧？绝对是的。职业运动员，是的，
but working in elite youth sport I actually quite find more enjoyment working along the pathways so I know there are people that find enjoyment in the glory of sport yes I've engaged with professional athletes in the past but I find there is more more joy developing the athlete at the early stages so youth sport is is actually my preference but because of the specialism with the EDI and investigating the racism you definitely do engage with more professional athletes in that regard yeah thank you I feel like my mindset has just pivoted from thinking of sport and exercise as something to dread as you know something to relish um and that's that's the difference and I do wonder whether had I had more opportunities so um in uh in the Olympics um London 2012 it's a bit of a running joke in my family that I was watching the pole vaults um and I was like oh I've never
但在精英青少年体育领域工作，我实际上发现沿着成长路径工作能带来更多的乐趣。我知道有人在竞技体育的光环中找到乐趣，是的，我过去也接触过职业运动员，但我发现在早期阶段培养运动员能带来更多快乐，所以青少年体育其实是我的首选。不过，由于涉及EDI（多元、公平与包容）的专长以及对种族主义的调查，你在那方面确实会接触到更多的职业运动员。是的，谢谢你。我觉得我的心态刚刚发生了转变，不再把运动和锻炼视为一件令人畏惧的事，而是视为一件令人津津乐道的事，这就是区别。我在想，如果我当初有更多的机会的话——所以在伦敦2012年奥运会上，
never done that this could have been my sport I could have been like an amazing pole vaulter and they were like I think you probably wouldn't have been but I was like but how do we know you know if we're not giving people a chance to try these things out how do we know yeah no I appreciate that to be fair and it kind of brings me back to the sentiment that you shared about you know allowing your children the opportunity to engage with sport very early on. I definitely do feel that even if they don't become you know professional athletes it's the character and the character building that comes as a result of participating in sports and team sports especially
我家里一直有个笑话，当时我在看撑竿跳高，然后我说：“哦，我从来没练过这个，这本可能是我的运动，我本可以成为一个了不起的撑竿跳高运动员。”他们就说：“我觉得你大概不会是的。”但我就说：“可是我们怎么知道呢？如果我们不给人们机会去尝试这些事情，我们怎么会知道呢？”是的，说实话我很赞同这一点，这让我想起了你之前分享的观点，即让你的孩子们在很小的时候就有机会接触运动。我确实觉得，即使他们没有成为职业运动员，通过参与运动——尤其是团队运动——所培养出的品格和性格，
you know learning those early principles of teamwork and you know respect and understanding that persons have differences different levels of abilities and acknowledging that persons have differences, different levels of abilities, and acknowledging that there is a role that you play within the team and taking that outside of sport and looking at life in general and your role in society and who you are and how you can make a contribution to not just society, but to another person and to the people that you interact with I definitely feel that these skills are transferable and I do feel that a lot of the
你知道的，学习团队合作的早期原则、尊重他人、理解每个人有不同的差异和不同的能力水平、认识到每个人都有差异、有不同的能力水平，并认识到你在团队中扮演着一个角色，然后把这些带到体育场外，审视日常生活、你在社会中的角色、你是谁，以及你如何不仅为社会做出贡献，还能为另一个人、为你与之互动的人做出贡献。我绝对觉得这些技能是可以迁移的，而且我真的觉得很多
principles from sport can be applied to youth development I guess but young people's life skills development very early on but that will take me down another tangent about the impact that the field can potentially have in terms of academia and in terms of primary education, secondary education but yeah I'm just very passionate about everything that we can do as a field. Good, I'm really pleased to hear that and you're fighting that corner and that narrative which is really important. It sounds like reading between the lines there's still much more self-direction for trainee sport and exercise psychologists than there is for clinical I know for counselling psychologists they kind of have to find their own placements and kind of negotiate all these
体育运动中的原则可以应用于青年发展，我想是的，极早地促进年轻人的生活技能发展，但这会把我引向另一个话题，即该领域可能在学术界以及初等教育、中等教育方面产生的影响，不过是的，我只是对我们作为一个领域能够做的一切充满热情。很好，听到这些我真的很高兴，你正在捍卫那个立场和叙事，这真的很重要。听起来，字里行间的意思是，对于见习运动与运动心理学家来说，相比临床心理学家，仍然有更多的自我指导。我知道对于咨询心理学家来说，他们必须自己寻找实习岗位并协商所有这些
placement hours whereas for clinical it's very much more you know you get told which placement you're going to and there's a placement supervisor to make sure you're getting your hours and kind of to mediate. Am I right in thinking that sport and exercise is still a bit more self-directed? Yeah, so for me and my experience of it, and I think in reflection, this is why I love the professional doctorate wrote. You are supervised by a BPS accredited supervisor usually the program leader is that person but the school so there are only three professional doctorates across the UK usually the staff that are employed also have their supervisory accreditation so you are allowed to kind of shape the way that you want
实习小时数，而对于临床心理学家来说，更多的是你知道的，你会被告知你去哪个实习岗位，并且有一个实习监督员来确保你获得了小时数并进行调解。我这样认为对吗：运动与运动心理学仍然更自主一些？是的，就我个人以及我对此的经验而言，回顾过去，这就是为什么我热爱专业博士学位路线。你由一名英国心理学会（BPS）认证的监督员进行监督，通常项目负责人就是这个人，但所在的学校——整个英国只有三个专业博士学位项目——通常受雇的员工也拥有监督认证，所以你可以塑造你想要的
your training to go and that was one of my first submissions um mark submissions on the professional doctorate so we we had to write up a plan of training where we projected exactly what we wanted to do to show how we intend to get to the end. And, you know, having successfully passed that, then you undertake your work and you actually meet with your supervisor to ensure that you are engaging in the opportunities that would allow you to kind of develop and grow. But equally, because I engaged in youth sport
培训方向，这是我在专业博士学位上的第一批提交作业之一，嗯，评分作业。因此，我们必须写一份培训计划，预测我们确切想做什么，以展示我们打算如何走到终点。而且，你知道，在成功通过之后，你就会开展工作，并实际与你的监督员会面，以确保你参与那些能让你发展和成长的机会。但同样地，因为我参与了青少年体育
and I worked in youth sport professionally in the Caribbean, those were the opportunities I saw when I came to the the UK so when I worked within Premier League football for example I kind of recognized okay well this is my strength and I was allowed to capitalize on that um and again confidently I speak about the work that I do at the youth level because I've just been allowed to specialize in that regard so I do find that that's a real benefit um in being able to yeah choose and kind of follow your passion in that regard um because then you could also use those CPD opportunities beyond qualification to further develop as well um but yeah that's I think is very much specific so by the end of it you are
并且我在加勒比地区从事过专业的青少年体育工作，当我来到英国时，这些就是我看到的机会。因此，例如当我效力于英超联赛足球俱乐部时，我意识到，好吧，这就是我的优势，我被允许充分利用这一点。而且，再次充满信心地说，我谈论我在青年层面所做的工作，是因为我刚刚被允许在该领域进行专业化发展，所以我确实发现这是一个真正的优势，能够选择并追随你在那方面的热情，因为这样你还可以在取得资格之后利用这些CPD（持续专业发展）机会来进一步发展。但是的，我认为这非常具体，所以在结束时你
supposed to come with a certain level of expertise in a specific area and I could definitely say no that that is youth sport and no definitely focusing that um this aspect of my professional development on the social advocacy so there are different branches of my practice that I feel are definitely warranted at this time so you you won't see me speaking a lot about the youth sport because I definitely find when clients get in touch when parents get in touch that's that's a no-brainer for me because I've done all the work in that regard when it comes to the social advocacy and you know sharing on LinkedIn and speaking up and speaking out and presenting publicly and delivering at my job it's definitely specific towards the cultural competence in that regard. Thank you and are there
应该在特定领域具备一定水平的专长，我可以明确地说，不，那就是青少年体育，而且不，绝对是将我的职业发展的这一方面聚焦于社会倡导。因此，我的实践中有不同的分支，我觉得在目前这个时期绝对是正当的。所以你不会看到我经常谈论青少年体育，因为我绝对发现，当客户联系时，当家长联系时，那对我来说是不需要动脑筋的事，因为我已经在那方面做好了所有的工作。当谈到社会倡导时，你知道，在领英上分享、大声疾呼、公开演讲并在我的工作中发表演讲，这绝对是针对该方面的文化胜任力。谢谢你，并且是否存在
sort of is there a cohort that you're all doing at the same same sort of time same sort of yeah so yeah definitely there were seven on my cohort so the intake is seven per year at my alma mater I'm I can't speak to others but you definitely do have a cohort of trainees that you work with and it's very good to kind of have the community to share those experiences with as well. Yeah I definitely agree like it can be so validating can't it of the experiences but also motivating to be part of that kind of group and how about qualified life are you self-employed? I am I well don't let me say self-employed per se. I work at a university. I would say, well, world-renowned.
某种，是否存在一个你们大家在同一时间、大致相同时段都在参与的同辈群体？是的，确实如此，我的同辈群体里有七个人，在我母校每年的招生人数是七人，我不能代表其他人，但你确实有一个与你合作的同辈学员群体，拥有这样一个社区来分享这些经历也是非常好的。是的，我绝对同意，这会带来极大的认可感，不是吗？对经历的认可，而且作为那个群体的一部分也非常具有激励作用。那么关于合格后的生活，你是自雇的吗？我是……嗯，别让我说我是自雇的，本身来说。我在一所大学工作。我想说，嗯，世界闻名的。
It's the best university for sport. But I do consult, again, because of the limitations to the visa. I consult 20 hours per week. And definitely the research and the work that I'm undertaking in my academic job is continuing to fuel the evidence base for the work that I do in my practice. So we're at the lovely intersection where a passion and a profession meets. And I'm really excited for the next few months. We've got some things in the works and yeah so I'm presently based at Loughborough University and utilising the space is a fantastic space to be in at this time an exciting space for EDA in line with the university strategy and I'm definitely having the opportunity to put forward my research
它是最好的体育大学。但由于签证的限制，我依然做咨询。我每周咨询20个小时。毫无疑问，我在学术工作中进行的研究和工作正在不断为我在实践中所做的工作提供证据基础。所以我们处于一个激情与职业相遇的美好交汇点。我为接下来的几个月感到非常兴奋。我们有一些项目正在进行中，是的，我目前在拉夫堡大学，并在这个空间里发挥作用，在这个时候，这对于符合大学战略的多元、包容与反种族歧视（EDA）来说是一个绝佳且令人兴奋的空间，我绝对有机会提出我的研究
develop and build so I am definitely reflecting a lot more on the professional doctorate and just how it's brought me this far. Amazing and ultimately would you hope to get indefinite leave to remain? Honestly I haven't thought that far ahead mainly because again because of everything we highlighted earlier home is always home and I see every opportunity for what it is and yeah no I haven't thought that far ahead I'm contracted at the university so I'll be very open about that so there will be a time where my tenure will come to an end and when that comes to an end then a new journey will begin um whether you care abroad I can't say but I'm definitely not the person to decide um that that's where yeah that's where I'd want to be where was I gonna yeah is there uh thank you so much yeah I couldn't agree
进行开发和建设，所以我确实对专业博士学位以及它如何带我走到这一步进行了更多的反思。太棒了，最终你是否希望获得无限期居留权？老实说，我没有想那么远，主要是因为正如我们之前强调的一切，家永远是家，我看待每一个机会都只看它本身的价值，是的，不，我没有想那么远。我和大学有合同，所以我对此非常坦诚，所以总有一天我的任期会结束，当那个结束时，新的旅程就会开始。无论是出国发展，我无法确定，但绝对不是我来决定，那就是，是的，那就是我想去的地方。我刚才要说什么……是的，非常感谢，是的，我不能再同意
more that um you know the world is your oyster as we say um and is your qualification recognized internationally so it's a UK qualification but can you take that and and run with it most definitely Sandow's of proficiency um particularly with respect to the bps and bases so there is another route to qualification sorry you can end that as well the qualifications um are recognized all over the world um so truthfully let's say for example i decided i want to work in australia there are certain things that you'd have to do to adapt um you know they they kind of investigate the learning that you undertook and yeah you will have to do some training in line with their actual framework but essentially it is possible to just kind of adjust
更多了，正如我们所说，世界是你的舞台。你的资历是否获得国际认可？这是一个英国资历，但你能拿着它并在世界各地大显身手吗？完全可以，熟练度标准，特别是关于BPS和BASES（英国体育与运动科学协会）的标准，所以还有另一条获得资格的途径，抱歉，你也可以结束那个。这些资格在世界各地都得到认可。所以坦白说，比方说，如果我决定我想在澳大利亚工作，你必须做某些事情来进行调整，你知道的，他们会调查你所进行的学习，是的，你必须根据他们的实际框架进行一些培训，但本质上，完全有可能进行调整
and adapt um to gain accreditation wherever you decide to travel um so yeah the UK qualification definitely holds some weight when we consider transnationalism and working abroad. One thing that I think has been quite astounding for me, again being in academia coming from an international route as I would have shared with you, is the relatedness I find especially when I deliver to international students and when people see me taking up this space and knowing that I've done this from an international route most people just want to know how I've gotten it done and being able to engage with students in particular to share with them okay well this
和适应，以便在你决定去哪里旅行时获得认证。所以，是的，当我们考虑到跨国主义和在国外工作时，英国的资历绝对是有分量的。我认为对我有很大触动的一点是，作为一名有国际背景的学者来到学术界，正如我曾与你分享的那样，我发现了一种共鸣，特别是当我向国际学生授课时，当人们看到我占据这个空间，并且知道我是通过国际背景做到这一点的，大多数人只想知道我是如何做到的，特别是能够与学生互动，与他们分享，好吧，这就是
is where I started and this is where you could potentially be being that person that they could see themselves in I think to some extent and recognizing that there is an end goal and sharing the story to allow them to feel as if you know it will come to an end does help a lot and I feel really pleased to be able to support students in that regard um not just at my institution but wherever um and I think with the international student crisis um particularly with students looking towards the UK for example to explore their prospects having more professionals like myself who will actually motivate them to kind of come to the UK and to stay in the UK, I think is quite important at this point in time. International students invest a lot and I don't think people understand the amount of investment
我开始的地方，这就是你潜在的可以到达的地方，成为那个他们能看到自己身影的人，我认为在某种程度上，认识到有一个最终目标，并分享这个故事让他们觉得，你知道，这一切都会有终点，这确实很有帮助。我感到非常高兴能够在这方面支持学生，不仅在我的机构，而且在任何地方。我认为随着国际学生危机，特别是当学生希望来到英国探索他们的前景时，有更多像我这样实际上会激励他们来到英国并留在英国的专业人士，在目前这个时间点显得相当重要。国际学生投入了大量资金，我不认为人们理解其中涉及的投资量
that goes into not just financial but emotional investment to adapt into a different country, a different culture, different climates. So I'm glad to be here to help support students in that respect. And we'll see how it continues. Thank you. That's been really, really interesting discussions that we've had. But also thinking about your reflections on that has been yeah really lovely to hear actually so thank you for your time if there's a small piece of advice for helping people not burn out in this field of psychology what would yours be my would be self care um and it's interesting because i'll be presenting at an upcoming Congress in the summer.
不仅是财务方面的，还有情感上的投资，以适应不同的国家、不同的文化、不同的气候。所以我很高兴能在这方面帮助支持学生。我们将拭目以待它将如何继续。谢谢你。我们进行的这些讨论真的非常非常有趣。同时，思考你对此的反思，听起来也确实非常美好，所以谢谢你的时间。如果有一个关于帮助人们在这个心理学领域不至于筋疲力尽的小建议，你会给出什么？我的建议是自我照顾。有趣的是，我将在今年夏天的一个即将召开的大会上发表演讲。
And I've been invited to present about self-care from an ethnic diverse perspective, as I was told. And self-care is of utmost importance and understanding what that looks like culturally is equally important. And we talk about supporting people individually but we as practitioners sometimes do not consider our own self-care as much as we should and I would tell any upcoming professional even even even undergrads you know begin to consider the strategies that work for you especially when you consider the level of commitment that goes into any form of study, any form of training. So I can't tout self-care enough. Absolutely. So very important. And we need to be able to look after ourselves first, put that gas mask on ourselves first before we can help anybody else, don't we?
正如我被告知的那样，我被邀请从多元族裔的角度就自我照顾发表演讲。自我照顾是至关重要的，理解它在文化上是什么样的同样重要。我们谈论单独支持人们，但我们作为从业者有时并没有像我们应该的那样考虑我们自己的自我照顾，我会告诉任何即将步入职场的专业人士，甚至甚至是本科生，你知道的，开始考虑适合你的策略，特别是当你考虑到投入到任何形式的学习、任何形式的培训中的承诺水平时。所以我怎么强调自我照顾都不为过。绝对的。非常重要。我们必须能够首先照顾好自己，首先戴好我们自己的氧气面罩，然后才能帮助别人，不是吗？
Most definitely. Thank you so much for your time. If people want to follow you or get in contact where's the best place for them to do that um afro sports sake that's on instagram that's on twitter um or you can just connect with me on linkedin dr don marie armstrong and that's where you'll find me it's lovely i will make sure all of those bits are on screen for people watching on youtube and they'll be in the show notes um for people that listen on mp3 thank you so much for your time it's been really lovely getting to know you and wishing you well with your publications and what comes from future thank you yeah thank you thank you so much and all the best to you as well thank you thank you so much to my guest for today, Dr. Dawn Marie Ambrose. Please
完全同意。非常感谢你的时间。如果人们想关注你或者与你取得联系，最好的地方在哪里？嗯，Afro Sports Therapy，在Instagram上，在Twitter上，或者你可以在LinkedIn上与我联系，Dr. Dawn Marie Armstrong，这就是你能找到我的地方。很好，我会确保所有这些信息都会显示在YouTube观众的屏幕上，并且会放在节目简介中，供那些通过MP3收听的人参考。非常感谢你的时间，认识你真的非常高兴，并祝愿你的出版物以及未来的一切都顺利。谢谢，是的，谢谢，非常感谢，也祝你一切都顺利。非常感谢今天的嘉宾，Dr. Dawn Marie Ambrose。请
do go and connect with her on socials. She's just a joy to speak with. And I hope that my path crosses with her further in future. Has this evoked any thoughts, feelings, ponderings for you? Do come and let me know on my socials. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And do bear in mind the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Also,uk and then look at the free resources tab. It is called the free declensi guide, but it is relevant for all areas of. So grab your copy. Please do take a moment to rate and review this podcast if you are an Apple podcast fan. If you're on Spotify, please do rate the episodes. Please follow the show and subscribe
务必去社交媒体上与她联系。与她交谈简直是一种乐事。我希望未来我的道路能与她进一步交汇。这是否勾起了你的任何想法、感受或沉思？快来我的社交媒体上告诉我吧。我到处都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。请记住免费的Facebook群组：Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent。还有，在 uk，然后查看免费资源选项卡。它被称为“免费精简指南”（Free Declenst Guide），但它适用于所有领域。所以快去获取你的副本吧。如果你是苹果播客的粉丝，请花一点时间给这个播客评分和评论。如果你在Spotify上，请给这些剧集评分。请关注这个节目并订阅
if you're on YouTube. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you have any ideas for future podcast episodes, please don't be a stranger. Come and connect with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. It's a pleasure to be part of your world thank you for trusting me to help you in your journey do bear in mind the aspiring psychologist membership if it's your time and you're ready for the next step thank you again take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
如果你在YouTube上。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你对未来的播客节目有任何想法，请不要见外。来与我联系，我是 Dr. Marianne Trent。很高兴成为你世界的一部分，感谢你信任我陪伴你的旅程。如果你准备好迈出下一步，请记住 Aspiring Psychologist 会员资格。再次感谢，保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么就让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这就是 Aspiring Psychologist 播客。我是 Dr. Marianne Trent。我叫贾娜，是一名见习心理健康从业者，我读了临床
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体书籍，我发现其中所有的不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。有多少不同的途径可以达到目标，以及成为心理学家没有完美的方式，这让我感到非常惊奇，这让我充满信心，认为我并没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。